[Music]
do
judging however is also to be looked at
as a positive act of thought and has a
positive content
through this aspect the contradiction
present in the apprehending
consciousness and its identity with the
first consciousness
becomes still more complete the
consciousness that acts declares its
specific action to be a duty
and the consciousness that judges it
cannot deny this for
duty itself is the form which lacks all
content but
is capable of any in other words the
concrete action which in its
many-sidedness
is in its own self-diverse contains
the universal aspect that which is taken
as duty
just as much as the particular aspect
which constitutes the share
and interest of the individual in the
action
now the judging consciousness does not
stop short at the former aspect of duty
at the doer's knowledge of it
that this is his duty and at the fact
that the doer knows it to be his duty
the condition and status of his reality
on the contrary it holds to the other
aspect
looks at what the action is in itself
and explains it as resulting from an
intention
different from the action itself and
from selfish motives
just as every action is capable of being
looked at from the point of view of
conformity to duty so
too can it be considered from the point
of view of the particularity of the doer
for qua action it is the actuality of
the individual
this judging of the action thus takes it
out of its
outer existence and reflects it into its
inner aspect
or into the form of its own
particularity
if the action is accompanied by fame
then it knows this inner aspect to be a
desire for fame
if it is all together in keeping with
the station of the individual without
going beyond this station
and of such a nature that the
individuality does not possess its
station
as a character externally attached to it
but through its own self gives filling
to this universality
thereby showing itself capable of a
higher station
then the inner aspect of the action is
judged to be ambition
and so on since in the action as such
the doer attains to a vision of himself
in objectivity
or to a feeling of self in his existence
and thus to enjoyment
the inner aspect is judged to be an urge
to secure his own happiness
even though this were to consist merely
in an inner moral conceit
in the enjoyment of being conscious of
his own superiority
and in the foretaste of a hope of future
happiness
no action can escape such judgment for
duty for duty's sake
this pure purpose is an unreality it
becomes a reality in the deed of an
individuality and the action is thereby
charged with the aspect of particularity
no man
is a hero to his valet not however
because the man is not a hero but
because the valet is a valet
whose dealings are with the man not as a
hero but as one who eats drinks and
wears clothes
in general with his individual wants and
fancies
thus for the judging consciousness there
is no
action in which it could not oppose to
the universal aspect of the action
the personal aspect of the individuality
and play the part of the moral valet
towards the agent
there are a number of famous quips
little quotes and passages in hegel's
phenomenology of spirit and here in
paragraph 665 we get one of them
towards the end some of you may
recognize this
no man is a hero to his valet and
it continues we'll look at what he says
there
but i i've rephrased it slightly so that
it's a little bit more
gender inclusive why should men
be the only people to be you know
demythologized or unmasked in this way
by their
by those who serve them why not
everybody no one is a hero
to their valet in german as gift
kainen helden ferdin camardiner
so the comedienner is somebody who
serves a person
in rather intimate ways you know hegel
at the end
talks about this person seeing the
the hero the dealings with the person
not as a hero but
one who eats drinks and wears clothes
and he's actually being a little bit
delicate
in this way or decorous because they're
also the one who empties the chamber pot
they're also the one
who you know witnesses the the
coming home late and flopping down
in bed and then taking off their clothes
after the dance of this person
or they're the one who has to shine the
muddy boots after cleaning them
we could go on and on and on they're the
one who sees the person
behaving in ways that are not heroic
and we'll come back to this in in a
moment this intimacy that this this
affords
who is the valet in this case well it's
the
apprehending consciousness the universal
consciousness that we saw
doesn't act but engages in judgment
judgment of what of the other the acting
consciousness and in this this entire
long
section we have a really interesting
examination of how
actions and the actors those who are
engaging in the actions
can be interpreted now hegel is not
putting this forth
as like his general theory of action at
this point any more than he
he was in previous paragraphs
particularly in the reason
and the uh spirit section where we've
looked at action in a number of
different ways
particularly here in this morality
section
but what we can say is that
hegel is showing us a very
general way in which actions do get
interpreted
by those who themselves are not
necessarily engaging in the action but
looking at it from the outside
it could also be internalized as he's
held out right
the acting consciousness does have these
two sides of the individual
acting consciousness the universal
within them
which could be judging them from within
as well you might say that every one of
us insofar as we are
a hero acting we contain our own
valet we contain our own uh you know
chamber servant right
so let's let's look at what he has to
say here this is a very very interesting
and important paragraph he says
judging is also to be looked at as a
positive act of thought and has a
positive content
now that's rather promising isn't it and
he's not going to realize that promise
here in that paragraph where we expect
him to go immediately after that is to
say
oh you know the the judging the thinking
the apprehending consciousness
you know thinking is also an action it
is also
handled he doesn't do that
that's that's not where this is actually
going
it is going to advance the dialectic
as we see he tells us through this
aspect the contradiction present
in the apprehending consciousness in the
thinking
the universal consciousness and its
identity with the first consciousness
the one who's individuated and
acting becomes still more complete
so so how how does it become more
complete
there is an action going on here an
action of advancing
as i just said the dialectic through
thinking out
what is actually going on and then
taking it
on as one's own condition
as well and so we can we can
look at this in two different ways we
can look at
what the the movement is
as it's being sketched out by hegel here
we can also
view this as what apprehending
consciousness at this point would be
applying to our soul
to itself and it's something that we
ourselves could take on and think about
how we understand our own
motives and i'll say one thing before we
dive into this
so the valet interprets
motives as self-centered as coming out
of one's own
natural being the hero is a
is a hero but is not a hero to the valet
precisely because of the perspective the
valet has
which is a real perspective you know the
hero
does eat get dressed goes to the
bathroom
you know scrubs them themself of of
their sweat and
you know tries to eliminate their body
odor by all sorts of perfumes or oils or
carrying around
little sticks or things like that burps
you know does all these these things
that make them seemingly
less heroic right and the camera there
isn't a camera to cut away
and not look at that stuff or editing to
you know
mute out those sounds the sniffing that
might be happening or whatever else
is going on the valet sees the reality
of the person
and insofar as you are looking at
yourself through the eyes of the valet
you are understanding yourself in that
way
as this this body that's you know moving
around and
doing whatever it does and you can
understand your own actions
as not necessarily motivated solely by
as he says duty for duty's sake
but there's there's more going on
in in the picture here so anyway he goes
on and he says
the consciousness that acts declares
its specific action and so here the
specific action
action tun all right most of the time
he's using the word handle
behavior here he's considering a
specific
action bashtimtas determinate uh
some sort of action that they have
decided upon
you can think of action in this sense
as like considering the options in front
of you and zeroing
in that would be another way to talk
about it and it declares this to be
duty to be what it ought to do to be in
accordance
with with duty fleet right moral
obligation
and he goes on and he says the
consciousness that
judges it cannot deny this
why not why why can't the consciousness
that judges say
you're being a hypocrite like it did
earlier you're not really doing your
duty
well because duty is something
that is universal and therefore
is a form that can be filled in by
whatever content we
want he says duty is the form that lacks
all content but is capable
of any and and who decides what the
content is going to be the person who's
actually acting the acting
consciousness the one who does who
decides
who commits who acts within the world
so he says in other words the concrete
action
and now here he uses the word handle not
just hot
which in its many-sidedness is in its
own self
diverse contains the universal
aspects now that's interesting so
action is many-sided right it can be
looked
at in multiple ways it can apply itself
to multiple
things it's also many cited in that
there's
multiple components to action there is
in fact
motives intention conditions
all these things that we saw as we were
looking at actions
earlier on in the morality section and
also in earlier parts of reason and
and spirit so action is really something
when it's concrete it is really
something quite
complex quite quite many-sided and the
universal consciousness has to recognize
a certain kind of universality
there in action the action of
the person the individual so he says
it contains the universal aspect that
which is taken as duty
just as much as the particular aspect
which constitutes the share and interest
of the individual in the action
so you never get one without the other
if you want somebody
to act in a certain way you do have to
also take into account who they are
their circumstances
the circumstances in which you want them
to act
their own background their own
intentions their motives their
you know we could go on dispositions
their relationships with others we get
very very
complicated with this can't we
so these are both sides to the
acting person and now we've got a
certain kind of universality here
so here's where it gets really
interesting
so the judging consciousness does not
stop
short at the former aspect of duty at
the doer's knowledge of it that it is
his duty
and at the fact that the doer knows it
to be his duty the condition and status
of
of his reality so the acting
consciousness
doesn't just declare things to be their
duty and then do them
they know things to be their duty they
they go through a reasoning process
sometimes or
they rely upon their training or they
consult their conscience or whatever it
is they they have knowledge
that something is what they ought to do
their moral
obligation and then either they do it or
they don't do it or maybe they half-ass
it and do it part way and don't
persevere there's all sorts of
possibilities
in this case we we have a acting
consciousness that doesn't
right and then we have the apprehending
consciousness and
apprehending consciousness gets what the
acting consciousness is saying about
what it's doing but it doesn't entirely
buy it
instead the apprehending consciousness
at least in its own view sees more
it posits more right so it says on the
contrary it holds to the other aspect
looks at what the action is in itself
so this could be done in a lot of
different ways i'm sure for some
readers this makes you think about you
know
kant and you know determining what the
maxim of one's action
is and what kant does in talking about
that
is not something really radical or
something new
thomas aquinas called this determining
the moral species of an action right
in the 20th century we would call this
in in moral philosophy
the proper description of the action
you know and and if you look backwards
you see a lot of people discussing this
in a lot of different ways
how do we make sense out of what the
action
is as such
and hegel goes on and says
they explain it as resulting from
something else so this is where we might
think for a minute so
when we decide on actions how does that
actually work
we have a particular thing that we think
is our our duty or what we ought to do
and then we will to do it right
well what gets us to will to do it in
some respects the will
is self-determining and that always
scares people because
that makes it arbitrary or in german
velcro leak right
like a will um in in some respects
but the will it doesn't just decide out
of a vacuum
it has intentions
right in in german what you have in mind
to accomplish with the action before you
do the action you have an intention and
then you do it
and what motivates intentions well
motives right motivations
and we can talk about one's motivational
structure
and how that interconnects with and
helps to motivate the will
the will can by the way work on itself
in in at least by
the perspective of some moral
philosophers and say i
want to reject this motive i want to you
know amplify
this other motive but the will is
motivated by
motives and so the acting person has
something in the background and the
question is where does this come from
and how where are we of these
so the apprehending consciousness the
one who's engaging in judgment
says it looks at the action and explains
that it is resulting from an intention
different from the action itself and
from
selfish motives eigen nuts again
tribe fader right fader sorry
so things that are that are essentially
self-centered or coming out of the self
that one
is not coming from some
duty for duty's sake which he's going to
decry in just a little bit
he says just as every action is capable
of being looked at from the point of
view of conformity to duty it can also
be considered from the point of view
of the particularity of the doer
why because as an action as something
that
is real happening in the world or even
happening within one's body or
one's consciousness it is the actuality
of the individual you you can't do
actions in general you have to actually
do
an action you know if i want to scratch
my face with a finger
because i've got an itch i can't just
have like finger in general doing the
scratching
or else i'm going to keep itching i got
to pick is it going to be this finger
or maybe my thumb or i'll reach behind
and reach around and it'll be this this
index finger on the other hand because
i'm
like a virtuoso of of scratching my face
or some
some silliness like that right you can
apply this to anything
and and this by the way is something
that hegel makes as a general point
in other places like he's talking about
you know the silliness of desiring fruit
and passing up every single fruit that's
offered to you no no i don't want apples
don't want oranges don't want this don't
want that you know you got to pick a
fruit an
action has to happen by somebody
actually veer clique doing the action
so now that raises a problem the actor
who is a particular
has particular motives now here's where
it starts to get
kind of kind of funny right
and here's where we can say are we
really sure that the apprehending
consciousness is getting things right
hegel's not worried about that he's
being you know good phenomenologist
following along
seeing what this is apprehending
consciousness is up to
and so it looks at the person's actions
now here we go through a couple examples
we could multiply these examples uh
manifold maybe i'll come up with a few
after we look at hegel's so he says
this judging of the action takes it out
of its outer existence
what we can see and
reflects it into its inner aspect into
the form of its own particularity
what we're saying is this is what's
really going on in the person's
mind or heart if the action is
accompanied by fame
then it the judging consciousness
knows this inner aspect to be a desire
for faith
so if you wind up being famous that must
be what you were aiming at right
if it gets you uh people
opening doors for you and giving you
candy
and you know shoving microphones in your
face that must be what you were aiming
at at the whole time that was your
intention
coming out of this motive and you're
calling what you're doing duty but it's
not
really duty it's really
being famous right
so if you were for example is one close
to
myself if you were creating youtube
videos
because you found that you had a
facility with explaining certain
concepts from
texts and thinkers and um
they turned out to be helpful for people
and they got
shared and you know you got you know
subscribers and views that was what you
were after in the first place
so you know this is a little bit
arbitrary isn't it
how do you know it was that and not
making a ton of money well because you
don't make a ton of money on youtube
unless you're doing cat videos or makeup
tutorials or stuff like that but how do
you know it wasn't this other thing or
this other thing or this other thing
the apprehending consciousness is
positing
this let's look at the next example
which is even
more interesting is a little bit more
convoluted
if it is all together that is the action
in keeping with the station of the
individual
their their job their rank their
position we would say
without going beyond this station so
you're staying within your job
description
and of such a nature that the
individuality does not possess its
station as a character externally
attached to it
but through its own self gives feeling
to this universality
thereby showing itself as capable of a
higher station
so you know how do we translate that
into more contemporary terms
you're on the job you have been assigned
some tasks you're fulfilling them well
and you're not just doing so because
somebody is making you do it
you are like you know throwing yourself
into your work as we say well then that
shows that you're capable of better
things so management takes notice of you
and they're like oh we got to promote
this person we're going to give them a
higher
station and it works this way in
hierarchical organizations doesn't it
i mean there's a little bit of a side
note if you've never read the book the
peter principle
read it because it's it's about
hierarchical organized
you know structures like the military
the church academia
where people can move up by doing their
job well at the position that they're at
and then somebody says oh well they they
deserve a promotion
and sooner or later everybody gets
promoted to a position
where they're no longer capable of
handling the duties
of that and they start screwing up and
then they don't get promoted
anymore well this is a you know peter
saw this as sort of a
universal dynamic it may not be that but
something like that is being imputed
here by the apprehending consciousness
isn't it says it shows itself the inner
aspect of the the action is judged to be
ambition ambition for higher
position so you know you do a good job
as a dog catcher
well maybe we should vote you in as a
city councilor do a good job as a city
councilor
maybe you should be you should be
exploring becoming a mayor and then you
know after that maybe
governor or after governor than
president
right and so on and so forth people
might do this
getting outside of their lane as well oh
you're a great lawyer you should be the
president yeah maybe not
um anyway he he gives these as examples
and he says that um since the action as
such
in the action is such the doer attains
to a vision of himself an objectivity or
to a feeling of self in his existence
thus to enjoyment the inner aspect is
judged to be an
urge to secure his own happiness
so what we're seeing here these are the
motivators right
a vision an onshowing
intuition of oneself in
objectivity getting an objective
viewpoint of oneself
being able to see oneself as an object a
gegenstand
right being able to like look at oneself
and say i'm the kind of person who does
this
sort of thing feeling of oneself
zelps in one's existence in design
feeling of oneself and one's existence
and thereby
enjoyment good news right these are all
oriented by this urge to secure
one's own happiness in german tribe
a drive to knock eigen or gluck zelight
luxaide kite happiness
you know literally like eudaimonia kind
of happiness or or the
you know more psychological happiness i
get one zone
one's own happiness your your intention
is not the same thing as duty your
intention is to make yourself happy
by saying oh what a great guy i am i'm
the person who pursues duty and look
look at the next thing he says right
after this right um
even though this were merely to consist
in intermoral conceit in the enjoyment
of being conscious
of one's own superiority and the
foretaste of the hope of future
happiness
and then hegel goes on and he says no
action can escape such judgment
for duty for duty's sake this pure
purpose is an unreality it just doesn't
exist
people behave the way that they do
because they're going to get something
out of it and it's motivated and they
have intentions
that are like that here's where we get
to
uh it says it becomes an unreality in
the deed of an individuality the action
is thereby changed
charged with the aspect of particularity
here's where we get the famous line
no man is a hero to his valet and now we
need to fill in the gaps
because if we stop short there we'd have
this universal cynicism ah nobody's a
hero to their valet
everybody's kind of crap when you get
down to it you just gotta hang out with
them for a little while
and you see what garbage human beings
are
that's not what hegel is saying no man
is a hero to the valet
why because the valet that he says not
because the man is not a hero
but because the valet is a valet
whose dealings are with the man not as a
hero but one who eats
drinks wears clothes in general with
individual wants and fancies so this is
an interesting psychological observation
maybe a sociological observation
then he's applying it to how the
apprehending consciousness
looks at actions done by
specific people and this could also be
what the acting consciousness
internalizes and says about its own
actions oh i'm not really that good i'm
just doing you know the things that i do
to satisfy myself
so he says for the judging consciousness
there is no action
in which it could not oppose to the
universal aspect of the action the
personal
aspect of the individuality and play
the part of the moral valley
towards the agent so this is why the
whole
hero valet thing is coming in here it's
because that is what the apprehending
consciousness is doing
in relation to the acting consciousness
it is behaving
like a valet it's attributing these kind
of
selfish base motives to
you know the person who's acting and
saying this is what's really driving
them
not their knowledge not the the duty
itself
not the necessity of acting not anything
particularly good in their character
it's unable to see the hero side of it
which implies that maybe there is
at least in some cases still a hero side
there
in the background or in the acting
consciousness
you